thank you
[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm gonna give
you 10 extremely important body signs
that you should not ignore as a man your
body is communicating to you giving you
certain signs about your health that you
should not ignore just like the way
nature gives us certain signs before
rain or a storm so let's start with
number one
weight loss for no good reason I mean
this is awesome if this is what your
goal was you know you've been hitting
the gym you've been eating healthy and
you've been losing weight but it's not
great if it suddenly happens for no good
reason this could be a sign of
depression stress cancer infection a
side effect of medication or even a
digestive disorder
[Music]
chest pain or any other kind of pain or
discomfort uncomfortable feeling in your
upper body you know people who get heart
attacks in movies you know they just get
a heart attack and then if they just
fall over that doesn't really happen in
reality it's something that happens
gradually it starts with chest pain or
you can even have pain or pressing
feeling in your neck or upper arms
erectile dysfunction now this is not
something to laugh about this is serious
because 70 of the cases are actually
caused by another health condition
so this should not be an ego thing
because this can happen to anyone causes
of erectile dysfunction are a high blood
pressure hormone problems vascular
disease
diabetes
kidney disease
multiple sclerosis heart disease and
neurological disease
and it also happens to men who drink too
much alcohol
bloody urine if you go to the toilet you
do your thing and you see that your
urine is red meaning there's blood in it
you need to take it seriously this is a
huge sign that you might have cancer or
an enlarged prostate other possible
causes are kidney stones or stones in
your bladder
[Music]
shortness of breath now this can be a
signal for a number of things like heart
attack can also be a signal for
congestive heart failure other possible
causes are lung cancer
asthma
pulmonary hypertension
emphysema
or chronic bronchitis
[Music]
a big belly you know those last few
decades a lot of more men started to
walk around with these big valleys so
much showed that some people think that
he's normal he's not normal some people
make fun of it and think it's funny it's
not funny either people say oh it's my
one pack I don't have a six-pack but I
have a one pack that I've worked really
hard for you know drinking a lot of beer
and they joke about it it's all fun and
games until the health conditions start
to get worse it is a sign of obesity and
the fat hanging in your belly increases
the risk of diabetes heart disease and
other health issues
right now you might be joking about it
but there will come a time where you
won't be joking about it anymore because
of all the pain that you're experiencing
because of your health conditions
you have to respect yourself enough and
your family to take better care of
yourself
constipation if you go to the toilet and
you're struggling to go then it can be
probably a number of things number one
you might not be eating enough high
fiber foods number two you might not be
drinking enough water or it might be a
more serious condition like bowel cancer
also watch out for symptoms like bloody
stools sudden weight loss fatigue
bloating gas or cramps now bowel cancer
it's Sneaky because it can be there for
several years before you are actually
experiencing any symptoms of it so be
careful don't play around with this go
see your doctor Oh and before I forget
if it's the first time that you're here
my name is Daniel and welcome to my
channel if you haven't subscribed yet
then please do if you don't feel like
you want to then just do it anyway I
would really love the support chances
are if you like this video you're
probably gonna like the other ones on my
channel as well let's move on to the
next one
foreign
too often if you always have the need to
go to the toilet often you probably need
to go and see a doctor about this
because chances are your body is trying
to tell you that you might have a
problem with your prostate or urinary
tract infection or number two you might
have diabetes causing you to be thirsty
all the time and drinking too much fluid
or three you might have an infection or
four kidney or heart failure
[Music]
difficulty swallowing you know if you
swallow you chew your food you go and
you swallow and you feel like man
something is off something is different
I'm struggling more than I used to it's
not going down smoothly it almost feels
stuck sometimes as well
then it's better to go and see your
doctor because chances are you might
have throat cancer which we know is
mostly caused by drinking and smoking
you can also experience sore throat too
much saliva weight loss difficulty
breathing normally and coughing up blood
[Music]
severe headaches I'm not talking about
just normal headaches there are a lot of
different types of headaches I'm talking
about these type of headaches that man
it feels like it is the worst headache
that you've ever experienced in your
life
If you're receiving those kind of
headaches go and see a doctor especially
if it falls under one of these
experiences number one it gets worse
over time two after having cancer three
if it is interfering with your daily
routine four the headache starts after
an activity like jogging cycling or
weight lifting 5. headaches from one eye
and the eye is turning red six if a
headache influences your vision now if
you want to know how to lose weight fast
or any other self-improvement tips then
watch one of these videos here and I'll
see you there and always remember before
you go life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys